[Applause]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they grew up to be classy or if they're
just big old piece of trash trash trash
trash I'm your host a Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toties in a new edition she's
upstairs sleeping one off okay in the
bathtub all right good for her to each
his own my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he is an international
businessman with International taste
give it up for KJ Kevin James ran I like
that one baby what's up everybody thanks
for tuning in likes the European
broads that ain't lying uh make sure you
Rie subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are RI cooking baby then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com garbage baby sign up
over there there's about 13,000 people
signed up already check it out gang and
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the old magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MCC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys I'm
stoked I'm so excited to meet this guy
talk about a guy who looks like he'd be
right at home sliding out underneath the
car carburator blown have that ready in
about two weeks gang the long hair ain't
lying cuz we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time he is a very
funny very successful standup comedian
actor and podcaster and you might have
seen him in but not limited to you got
laughs you got Jimmy Kimmel Live you
have Comedy Central lights out with
David Spade standup Nashville The
Tonight Show the stands up the standups
you can hear him regularly on the Nate
land podcast he has his own unbelievable
podcast we're having a good time and
he's got a brand new Netflix special out
right now in the top 10 working man give
it up for Dusty sleigh everybody let's
go there he is the kids in town hey
thank you we're having a good time I
appreciate you guys what a great intro
you know I've only listened to the
podcast I've never watched you it's
really fun to watch you guys we get into
it yeah that was fun the rest is
downhill both the first that first 90
seconds we're swinging for the fences
baby yeah you guys are like so good like
it's a real professional thing and it
feels good thank you buddy we're excited
to have you give us the uh the origin
story of Dusty slle give us the
backstory I would like to say you are
one of the most requested guests we've
had in a long time so it's uh I'm I'm I
I know there's a lot of dirt under their
fingernails I'm very pedigree I don't
know what it says about me that that
people are like you got to have this guy
on the are you garbage podcast you want
to see trash you guys haven't seen [__]
yet get Dusty up
there well uh okay well this is great
you know everybody loves to talk about
themselves that's what's great about
this job that I have where I just do
things and they go tell me about
yourself and I'm like ah I love this
yeah this is like a date where you like
get to do what you want to do sure you
don't care about what they did for a
living know where they went to school
yeah just fun man I love that okay well
uh I grew up in Alabama I grew I had my
parents got divorced when I was two and
uh so well then my dad says three
sometimes you really got to squeeze that
extra year out of you uh you know in
there I I wrote two jokes I put a joke
on each album about how my parents got
divorced when I was two and then my dad
was like you know you got divorced when
you were three and I'm like welll here
go back and re-shoot po I don't know why
you're that's all my dad does my dad's a
real nitpicky guy Hees to get at you he
go oh you know like I was at home uh at
his house this this over Christmas and
we we were ordering Subway and I don't
really eat Subway anymore but my dad
loves it they know him down at the
subway that's all the time we have today
folks and bigas big Christmas dinner huh
and I'm not eating it in a long time and
they were like what kind of bread do you
want to get and I was like I remember
there was like a Parmesan oregano there
was and I was like I'll have that my dad
goes why can't you just eat regular
bread first of all I don't think any of
it's bread yeah I was like I'm just
picking from the options that they here
with your Hollywood taste yeah like they
had you of course they they didn't have
it anymore and I was like of course uh
can I get that in a sushi roll is that
possible okay and then my dad ordered
pepper jack cheese so I was like oh look
someone hit the daily
number jack Chee thought was thought it
was European i' I've been watching a lot
of n Geo yeah my dad gets excited about
it he likes to get the foot long and
then he eats half that day and then the
next day he's like he's telling me how
the flavors sit in it does it does
though maybe it does it really comes
together overnight in at refrigerator or
left in the microwave either one but I'm
just like you're really selling me on
this Subway that I quit eating 10 years
ago sure yeah got to get back in there
baby Subway had a moment sure sure uh
but okay so Alabama so my dad lives on a
farm and uh he grew uh he lives on the
same farm that he was born in his dad
built his house in 1947 wow and he lives
there how many acres are we talking uh
he's got about 100 now 100 acres in
Alabama is he selling it off or is he
buying more he's trying to buy more you
know he's like over the years he's
bought both of the houses on either side
of him and the land that connects so now
he has pretty good some rental houses
what's he growing on there is he growing
anything just cows is what he does
really black really yeah now he's got
some chickens he used to have man I love
you he used to have an orchard where he
had a lot of apples that his dad planted
his dad died in 1966 and he had all
these apple trees that he planted and
then one day my dad just
bulldozes all the trees and I go what
what are you doing he goes I got tired
of cutting around
them hey I can't argue with the logic
I'm like you're got to get the weed
whacker out every 10 feet he's doing it
with a push mower like your dad's trees
that have been there for 40 years talk
about out with the old yeah what have
you done for me do with the cows uh he
he just raises them and then he sells
them for for beef or for beef like to
well I guess he just sells them to a a
cattle auction okay and then whatever
they do with it out of his show bus
whatever he won't get me a cow I'll tell
you that I I I told him that I was like
w you get a cow and I'll split it with
you okay and then he goes well everybody
wants to split a cow but all this money
that goes into days yeah you got to do
this and then I go well all right well
just get me a number number and I'll pay
you know and he go and then he's like
was going to split it between me and my
sister's husband that she's now divorced
from so we were going to do a three-way
split on a c and then when they got
divorced he goes well I figured you
wouldn't want it cuz he's gone now and
I'm like get the lawyers involved you
brought him in I didn't even I just want
some meat this is my deal Jerry So when
you say split a cat you want to get it
butchered and then you got the meet in
the fridge yeah I just thought you know
you know at least we know what's going
into this cow right I could get the meat
and then my my dad's he he raises cows
and then he buys meat from the grocery
store isett insane he's in there Larry
is that you not to mention what he could
have saved on apples yeah yeah I mean
and so uh and then I got you know I have
a younger sister with my dad my dad's
been married uh four times and uh his
wife current wife they've been married
for 20 years uh so pretty good that's it
gets longer each time with the exception
of my mom that was the shortest to marri
where did she fall in the she was the
second wife second wife second wife now
my mom came in with two kids so I have
two older sisters okay so that brings
you know that brings a bit that's a
little bit of baggage yeah my mom's got
a lot going on and so I can I can't
picture my parents married to each other
at all it doesn't make sense my mom's a
real like free free wheeling kind and
you know she likes her freedom and my
dad's a real control freak and I can't
see them being married at all um and so
I don't know how it worked I don't know
how and it didn't work when you were
born were you guys live with was the
whole family living in the house on your
dad's Farm yeah we were all living in
that house okay and then they got
divorced when I was two or three and in
between that time while they were
married I uh my they had this they had
like a uh I forget that it was like an
Olds mobile it was like a I I think it
was called like a 98 old the8 but it was
in you know 1984 sure I remember those
so it was so I was 21 months old and my
mom it was a bench seats my Mom leaves
me in a running car no car seat they
said there wouldn't car seats at the
time I don't know I I yes but I wasn't
strapped in either way she left me in
this running car and apparently I don't
remember but she left she went inside to
do something and I pulled the car down
into drive pulled a Ricky Bobby yeah and
then I went she left the car the car
door open and I went through a barbwire
fence and then in between two trees that
they said if I had hit the tree I
probably would have slammed into the
windshield I went in between the trees
it closed the door I went through
another barbwire fence and then crashed
the car in a pond Jesus what were your
first words rein's racing I guess so and
well my uh my mom can't swim and
so she goes running down there the car's
sinking uh she goes to the front door
the front door is like locked yeah so
she goes around to the side other side
of the car that door's locked and then
she opens the back door and she's like
I'm just standing there like pretty
happy and they and she pulls me out of
there and so that probably you know had
something to do with the
divorce I don't know if it was the
carelessness that my dad cared about so
much or if it was the um it was probably
the old mobile mobile yeah I mean that's
probably the nicest car my dad ever even
to this day maybe she left the end there
I'm in the middle of checking out don't
go anywhere yeah I don't even know what
she would have been doing she said she
was dropping off the mail but I I it's
like what just keep the mail in the car
what you what's going on here going
going all right and what did your mom do
for a living my mom for a long time
worked for a company that uh made VHS
tapes a company Factory called aex okay
uh and they you know they made a lot
they made the tape that goes inside of a
VHS tape gotcha so we all you know they
all thought they would retire from that
company that was big yeah and we were
the you know like probably the last
family to get into DVDs we were like
we're not we're not destroying the
family business here like like one time
I I lived in and my mom when they got
divorced I moved into a trailer park
with my mom and my other two sisters and
uh I remember a a a trailer a double
wide in the trailer park they had gotten
some laser disc and I went home talking
to my mom about it and she got real mad
at me about it she was like oh you're
always talking about all the stuff they
have and I'm like you know what I'm just
a kid here and I'm just obviously I
don't say this but I'm think I'm just a
kid I'm just telling you about things I
see see don't be mad at me you know what
I mean I didn't invest in it they
cutting your hours back at the factory
cuz no one's buying VHS anymore yeah and
you know thankfully laser disc didn't
work out so it stuck around for they
were the ones that were like the size of
Records oh they were real big yeah yeah
it was like a big deal I mean like well
a big deal for the people that bought
into it they loved it I remember a
teacher of mine was pushing that on us
real big I was like dude that thing
ain't fitting in my school bag get out
of here yeah yeah like records are on
the way out and we're trying to bring in
movie
records the record company was doing
that are even more delicate than the you
know a record it's like you know like a
piece of glass so you know so I moved in
with my mom they had joint custody and
then when I was five my dad married
another lady and you're how close in
where was was the trailer in your dad's
Farm about 30 minutes away and were you
split in time every other weekend I
would go to my dad's house and how much
older were your uh sisters on your mom's
side my mom my sister's there there 11
years old and 9 years old me all right
so my older sister was is really like
she's at my house right now she's like
like been like a real mom figure in my
life she's like the most uh like had it
not been for her who knows where I would
be I would be the bottom a pond in a
trailer park doing meth somewhere she is
the like she's the only one that's like
felt like she like really had it
together and she you know and she's even
she took me to a bar with a boyfriend
and I got burned in the head with a
cigarette you know those sorts of things
noral stuff so even that was like mother
figure yeah yeah real single mother
Vibes yeah I mean you know it's like my
all my family is so nice and I don't
ever think of them as like making all
these bad decisions when you look back
but truly they were making a lot of bad
decisions I got a cigarette burn on my
hand too oh yeah was an
accident but uh you know so you know so
I'm living in the trailer with my mom
and then my dad's married a lady with
two older you know has two boys that are
a little bit older than me okay and what
was a school public school public school
I went to yeah my step brothers were
they what do you think he was going to
private school just asking he was on the
BB gun team could have been homeschooled
I don't know he's at the bar getting
smoking sigs my dad was sending my Step
Brothers to private schools you go they
were going to you know a local private
school there in his County which is a
very small but the the movie Mississippi
buron uh they filmed all the downtown
scenes in my dad's homeown that's not a
good
sign yeah cuz they wanted you know in
the 80s they wanted a city that looked
like the 50s you know or 60s so so I met
Jean Hackman actually during that time
I have a video of me meeting Jean
Hackman it's on laser disc
yeah it's a video of my dad he's it's me
and my step brothers and my dad and my
dad like kind of pushes open the door
where Jean Hackman is and he's like he's
almost like he's like Jean can I get you
with my boys out here
and was it a restaurant it was like I
guess probably his hotel room I think it
was a barber shop they were
filming cut cut cut hold on a second now
and my dad tries to come in and he goes
Jean Hackman's like no I'll come out
I'll come out and then he comes out my
dad basically goes Jean Hackman like
he's ladies and gentlemen supposed to do
a little dance and so Jee amman's just
standing
there and Je what are you working on
these days huh he's doing panels he
looks at us and he goes oh he goes ball
players and uh my step brother's like I
am I am and then you hear me go I'm
not yes and what are you yeah play along
Dusty you're killing the segment Dusty
and then je this guy's going to
walk he does he gives me the kind of
like eyebrow raise of like
okay and you could it's a very clear
eyebrow raise of uh I can't even do it
and uh also as a kid I just picture you
right now but smaller that's how I how a
little bitty me high pitch boys I'm not
full beard long hair trucker hat and and
then Jean Hackman you know go goes all
right and then goes back inside and it
was just it was a big day I've shared
that video 10,000 times PR awes I wanted
that to be my viral moment that never
would be and maybe this would make it
there I I hope so um and so you know and
I was about 5 years old and then uh when
that happened shortly after that the
newspaper what are you talking about it
was a big deal deal there actually was
as you as I watch all my dad used to
film everything I have so many home vide
really that's awesome he had this VHS
tape he would just go and he would
always do that to people he would it
would be these real old country people
and my dad would go he go move around do
something he got 10 seconds before I cut
it can't find any Talent this town he's
like this is not one of them still video
camera you can move around for
mine he was always like bragging about
it putting other people's cameras down
sure and uh was it was it the big one
that went right into the
news got Dusty holding a boom mic and
everybody thought he was a time traveler
I mean I get that my dad was in
everybody's face with it but everybody
was so rude to my dad about it we're
eating dinner here Earl but now that all
these old people in my family are like
dying I got relatives reaching out to me
going hey do you got any of your dad's
videos of my mom or dad and I'm like
yeah but your mom's you know being mean
to my dad every time I can show you this
video your mom going get this out of my
face send over that Jean Hackman tape
will you Kip this is co-pilot shout out
to the co- gang if you're working out
stop selller for a boring treadmill run
at the gym shake things up with co-pilot
whether you like to work out at a recre
center or you want to keep those reps at
home co-pilot is your personal fitness
solution the app links you with an
affordable re Life Fitness coach who
will customize your workouts made
specifically for your needs and your
goals yeah it's easy peasy when you
don't want to get up and go to the gym
this is you know it's better than just
doing four setups and going I call it a
day I know what I'm doing they help you
do it they care of you if you're travel
a lot we're on the road a lot I've done
it in the hotel rooms I'm up there
Shadow Bo I'm taking care of things
fighting pillows the accountability
Factor makes co-pilot so amazing with
regular progress check-in support and
guidance no matter what your goal looks
like you're not alone baby give co-pilot
to try and find out why it was listed as
Forbes uh one of Forbes top rated
personal trainer apps of 2020 three uh
head to mycoop pilot.com garbage you get
a 14-day free trial and 20% off your
first month of personalized Fitness with
your own personal trainer if you sign up
before February 1st 2024 you get get it
in h do it before the before that date
that's my co-pilot
docomo help you reach your fitness goals
baby do it Kip this is fume shout out to
fume our old friends in fume Ben been
with us since Jump Street over there
fume gang is finally quitting the nasty
hand to mouth habit on your to-do list
this year if you're struggling to quit
bad habits it's time to check out fume
fume is an Innovative award-winning
flavored air device that totally turns
your habit on its head upside down keep
everything you've been doing take a step
outside fidgeting with your hands
getting a little break from the world
but the bad part of the Habit is
completely gone that's because instead
of vapor fume use flavored Air instead
of electronics fume is totally natural
instead of harmful chemicals fume has
delicious flavors uh yeah it's fantastic
they've been lucky uh nice enough to
send us it it's easy peasy it takes you
know it just gives you the all of the
same rituals the same movements the same
habits but it's not bad habits it's good
habits stick with the original or kick
things up a notch with the new Solano
fume it's made with premium Walnut
barrel and coated mouthpiece for a
slightly softer finish uh right now is
the best time to start uh the good habit
with fume all orders for the month of
January have a buy one get one cores so
you can stock up uh on that new for that
New Year's resolution plus are you
garbage listeners get an extra 10% off
when you use our code head to trif
nume.com garbage and use our code
garbage for an additional 10% off plus
BOGO buy one get one cores until January
31st to help make starting the have it
that much easier though it gang now back
to the show back to the show but as I'm
watching these videos you see more and
more people going yeah I went down there
trying to find Jee Hackman apparently
Jean Hackman was like a heartthrob in
some way yeah yeah I could see that back
in the day back in the day man I you
know I did watched the old Supermans and
he they were pushing him as like a
Playboy in those as a Playboy he was
like he's like Robert Downey Jr Iron Man
sure okay so your dad did pretty well
with the farm he was he making good
money yeah my dad sold insur he was an
insurance salesman so he had this he had
this real thing going he there was a
truck uh like a Truck Driving Center you
know like a I don't know what you would
call it but it's like a truck driving
company so they had all these truck
drivers so my dad would just sit there
he sold afflac and you would sell these
accident policies so he would just sit
there in the lobby and just sell
accident policies to these truck drivers
sh fish in a bar all day he would win
all these awards at afflac and win all
these the whole thing yeah my dad's been
all he's been you know to Canada and
Hawaii and New York City I mean you
would never think my dad would go to New
York City but it's like he went with
afflac he would win all these trips he
loves to tell the story he went to
Montreal and these girls were walking
real fast and he goes why you walking so
fast and they with a camera they go it's
cold my dad loves that story that's one
of his fa great dad story yeah and uh so
yeah my dad you know he did well with he
was doing well was your mom do your mom
was doing well the company she was
working at yeah I mean I think the the
factory was paying so well I think
that's why she left my dad she was like
oh I don't need this yes let me get out
of here and how was the double wide well
I was a single wide okay you know we
were a single wide but it was good I
mean I liked it I had a you know my mom
was good I was telling you that we
always installed our our carpets you
know but my mom was really like handy
like in a trailer they have these uh
particle board floors and over time like
the Heat and the moist will swell it up
in the so then it'll get real thin in
other places so the floor will just fall
through and like and my sister rented
and so they would just throw a piece of
plywood over top of the whole so you'd
have this little trip Hazard this little
one in trip Hazard I watched my nephew
he was living in a trailer one time and
he was showing me something and he had
all these dogs he had one sounds like
the worst hold on a second he was living
how old was the kid he was you know by
this he's 10 years younger than me if
his if his sister's 11 years older my
sister had a baby at 19 which is not bad
for how we grew up that's that's pretty
good and uh Bloomer yeah I actually have
a joke that I'm doing right now that I
love but I say uh I I I have kids now
and I always I wouldn't just do a joke
on you like this but I love this joke
and uh my sister uh well I have kids now
and I I always try to get people to have
kids because I like them and I was
telling my friend about it and she was
smoking a cigarette and she was like
dang I want to have a baby now too she
goes but then again if I get pregnant
you know I got to quit smoking and I was
like well I don't know you know my
sister smoked while she was pregnant and
it only took her 6 months to have a
baby that's a good piece of business
right there and that's my favorite one
of my favorite jokes now because it is
so true it is like she was dranking
heers obviously it's tragic at the time
but you know the kid lived he's he's 30
years old who was in the trailer with
you was it just you and your mom or it
was your sisters for a little while but
then they got their own well it was me
and my two sisters and my mom for for a
while my my my middle sister she would
go live with her dad sometimes right uh
their dad was still in the picture a bit
and uh so she would go live with him uh
he was a bit of an alcoholic I think
he's sober now he's a nice guy but he
doesn't he's still not a good like
Family Guy he knows a you know he's a
good farmer he knows about canning he'd
tell you all about chickens uh a line
that I wanted to be a good joke I say I
learned everything I know about chickens
from my sister's dad and I like that
because you know it's not my dad but the
audience never appreciated it they're
like yeah we're all from split up
families here okay get over it Dusty how
many bedrooms was the trailer it's a
two-bedroom trailer so how did how does
that break down well for a long before
you were there I was a couch guy I was I
was on the couch what age were we
talking uh from about either two or
three depending on who's telling the
story I guess until 14 is when we moved
out of the trail but you know at some
point they did all move out and I got my
own room okay you should have a book
called Dusty sleigh born to crash yes
well that's true I'm the couch I'm the
original couch Ser how would that how
would that break down at night like when
like when did you go to bed were they
just sitting there watching you would
just sleep was there any type of room
well we would you know a lot of times
your identity in the living room like
did you have little posters on the wall
or anything or you well you know I would
have stuff just in the other rooms you
know go in there and look at it like my
mom worked third yeah for a long time my
my sister had moved out and then my uh
my other sister and her boyfriend who's
now her husband live there so Jesus
Christ you guys are multiplying and my
mom worked third shift so I would sleep
with my mom until she went to work that
and then I would have the bed okay but
if I would wake up at night then I would
go get in the bed with my sister and her
boyfriend out of scared like fear yeah
and so I just liked it we were all tight
we were all buddies and I was like man
dude that's crazy that's where I wanted
to go to sleep anyway but they were like
go sleep with your mom how old we were
you in the middle between them or on the
end uh I you know we'd be
everywhere I can't call it well I had a
I bought like a bunch of cats just
walking in with a juice box you guys
doing some pal around you goofing I know
it had to be a real Buzz Kill for them
that's crazy that's crazy I bought an
army sleeping bag one time that had the
little uh you know had the little face
hole sure would sleep with my neck out
of it and my brother-in-law said I woke
up one time he said I I don't remember
it so I think I was asleep but I like
woke up in the night and I was like help
help and I was like trapped my
neck my neck was
trapped I just make sure your sister's
boyfriend being like what is this kid
deal
man [__] [__] block of the year were
you on the floor or were you in the bed
with I was on the floor at that time
okay and and well my my brother-in-law
he's from Michigan you know and he had a
pretty wealthy family and he his parents
both worked at General Motors my
brother-in-law went to the University of
Michigan he's the only person with any
education in the trailer at all my mom
didn't my mom didn't go to college my
both my sisters dropped out of high
school I mean it's like he's the only
one with any kind of education but
because we were all dumb we treated him
like he was the
idiot turning around on you right
like we're all dumb but we're all D we
all like hive mind dumb sure yeah you
guys control the narrative yeah and like
there was uh there was no internet back
then you know so he can't go look up one
time we spill just gas lightting this
dude thinking he's crazy we spilled milk
in the vent on the floor and he goes oh
it's going down the register and we lost
him we made fun of him about register
for so long because we didn't know
that's what it
yeah yeah yeah and we're like what an
idiot this is a vent you see any money
yeah and then my sister would cut his
hair and I remember one time like she
really like she using the Clippers and
like gave him a big like Gap all the way
up the back and we were laughing so much
that she couldn't even fix his haircut
this poor guy's like he's trying to work
a professional job and he's got this B
Gap up the back of his hair what did he
do well he well he actually what did his
family thing he came you said he came
from like he's a college educated guy
he's choosing to live in a trailer I
don't think they liked it I'll be honest
with and how long were they there a few
months a year two years uh that well he
got an apartment uh he always had an
apartment but he would stay with us with
they all the time okay gotcha but he had
you know had his own stuff at another
place how the hell didn't she stay at
his place well eventually that's what
happened but he probably had to be
watched if the mom went to if your mom
midnight you know 11 I really think he
liked it his family had money growing up
but they were like a colder family and
like we were like guys all goofing
around sleeping bunch of redneck he
called us hillbillies that was his
redneck wasn't popular back then he
always called us Hillbillies and uh I
don't think he was wrong yeah no but
like like one time he was like he wanted
to order Chinese food and apparently we
made fun of
him like we would only eat at Hardies
Hardies was Hardies and western western
Sion was a night out I mean it was and
then like we were like what are you
going to are you going to go to China to
get that that's how that's how stupid we
were like these were real thoughts to us
like Chinese food in Alabama grow
up why you go to the Moon while you're
at it
yeah [__] Buzz Light you're over here
what you slide down to register go get
your Chinese food okay and how was I
think I think you're the first uh if I
if I can recall through all the guests I
think you're the first guest to grow up
in a trailer correct I believe so maybe
I think someone I forget somebody might
25 people in it yeah for sure what was
the what was the trailer park community
like where you spend a lot of time
running around with the kids was there a
pool was there was no pool festivities
going on at all yeah we we were hanging
out I mean there was a lot of kids and
uh we have you know most of them I still
talk to to some degree
but uh you know you know some are dead
but uh most of them numbers price is
doing business
but break a couple of eggs you know what
I
mean but I do talk to a lot of them and
uh one guy uh we Nick nicknamed him
alarm clock because he would always come
down and knock on the door real early in
the morning trying to get me to come out
and the whole that's one of my family
come out to play yeah he just want to
play and you know we had a great time he
would always chew on his shirt he always
had a lot of rips on the bottom of his
shirt where he was like really tearing
at it man that's childhood drama yeah
yeah I think
so you're trying to run from stuff yeah
if you running out of the house at 5:00
a.m. eating your
shirt skipping breakfast I'm going to go
eat my shirt and talk to Dusty and then
his sister was a lot older than him and
she was really pretty hot uhuh and I I
remember she lived next door to us for a
little while and she was married to this
guy who like played at like a band like
the you know holiday in or whatever
locally and uh I remember me and my
buddy were out outside one time and we
could hear them having sex in the
bedroom from the outside yeah and we
were like oh that's it I mean cuz she
was hot like what I'm talking about but
his his her son is my age makes it all
worthwhile doesn't it and I talked about
it on my podcast one time that story and
her he listens and I didn't realize it
at the time and I was like oh that's
weird he never brought it up but um but
you know he heard it yeah and uh I was
like that was you know that was a real
highlight you know you hear some going
on you're like that yeah what was
the bike jump sit were you guys what
were the activities 100% bike jumping I
mean we had you know we had a lot of
bricks and cement blocks laying around
put a piece of two around 10 Woods all
over the place like in the back we had
we had just endless Woods I mean they
were not ours I don't know who they
belong to but everybody would hunt out
there like my all my family would come
and they would hunt we had no permission
to be out there just shooting we had a
loose permission from a guy that was
like uh I don't care if you do it kind
of thing but we don't really know that
he owned it they back there when you say
your family would come over your mom's
side of the family would go over to the
trailer park yeah my brother-in-laws
would hunt and my mom's boyfriends they
would come over and hunt they are they
walking deep out in there they're just
getting like 50 yard from the kit yeah I
wasn't sure we're going way out in there
and then I also had like I built a rope
swing out there swing out and there was
a
creek and I I love we love Creek stuff
you know getting uh tadpoles and little
salamanders out of and crawfish out of
the shout out the creek living baby they
were good years of your life man it is
so good 12 years old with a creek and a
couple of buddies catch a nice rainstorm
that thing swells up a little bit oh
yeah I mean between the dad my dad's
farm and and like the the woods we had a
we had a some Woods on the other side
where they had like Creek and then a a
this big rock we called it big rock
because it was just the and I tell
people I still back there's
neighborhoods back there now but the the
the creek is still there and you have to
just go out in there and uh I take
people sometimes we'll just go through
this neighborhood and then kind of drift
off in the woods and I tell them it's
called Big Rock and every time they see
it they're like whoa they're like
they're like I did not see this coming I
mean this should be a national park and
now it's just some Creek polluted by a
neighborhood damn maybe a state park I
don't know National Park a big yeah yeah
what were they hunting deer deer all
deer okay yeah you grew up eating a fair
amount of deer meat I still eat it I my
stepmom brings up deer meat she don't
hunt I don't know where she's getting
it she got some kind of deer meat
connection route 48 yeah she just brings
it up and it'll be in all these like
random meat bags you know that say like
you know not for sale you know stuff
like
that Best Buy date on it but there's no
date written in void of package
individually but when I you know when I
was five I was down hanging out at my
grandmother's house my grandmother lived
had a house and she lived you know this
is Alabama she had no air conditioner my
whole life she had no air conditioner so
it's like you go down there it's 100°
there's just an oscillating fan going
around just blow just a whiff of
slightly less hot air blowing on you and
you know my my cousin and uncle Liv next
door and my they had my grandfather's
old air rifle and my my cousin was like
the pump pumping it just pumping it I'm
five years old he's probably seven eight
and I was like I don't think you're
supposed to be playing with that and
he's like it's not loaded and we were
playing I was like famous last words I
was being He-Man he was being gii Joe or
I don't know he was being a [__]
yeah and I was like you know I have the
power and then my cousin shot me in the
chest with a BB gun at 5 years old it
went in my chest through my lung what uh
in my back I I went to the hospital wait
what an there was an exit wound Jesus
Christ no exit wound it's still in me to
this day I'll get x-rays sometimes and
it's still in you've been shot I went I
got an MRI done one time and they were
like do you have any shrapnel in your
body and I'm like well kind of I was
like and if this machine pulls this BB
out I want it yeah of course I don't I'm
putting it in a necklace and I'm wearing
this through your chest into your lung
through the lung through the lung and
then it landed in my back and I guess
the I stayed in the hos was a hell of a
shot I'm tell you that I think he tried
to kill me and uh and uh it just it was
did it hurt uh yeah you know I don't
remember pain necessarily but I remember
like not being able to breathe yeah the
Panic He-Man and then yeah I mean I I
always say you know I was Adam and had I
made the full transition boun off but I
never got to do it the lightning didn't
come down but I you know and the doctor
I guess was like you know I you know we
could do surgery and take it out or you
could just leave it in that doctor
definitely had a cigarette hanging out
in his mouth and my dad was like just
leave it in let's get out of here did
they fix the lung at all or does that
heal itself back yeah I don't think they
did anything they just kind of that's
crazy that's crazy and then I had an IV
I got video
obviously buddy I I mean I'm literally
I'm in the hospital I got a board on me
so that my I don't rip out the IV and
then I got all these IVs and I'm in the
bed and my dad's videoing me going do
something I'm not making my dad is like
move around he's like telling me I'm
like I'm in the hospital you ever see
the movie Butterfly Effect I wish that I
could do that sometime I wish that I
could Butterfly Effect back to all these
videos and tell some people off I would
just like to wake up in the hospital bed
as my full grown mind and tell my Dad
hey I'm in the
hospital video me but I'm not going to
be moving around dude talk about built
for the show crazy this is like we're
the Yankees in the 80s and there's like
there's a guy named Dusty SLE throwing
102 down in Cuba we got to get him got
to get them wow yeah so it's like and
then after that my I kept my my stepmom
would always fix my meals at my dad's
house and I kept coming home to my mom's
house and I would be sick and my mom
still to this day thinks my stepmom was
poisoning me and my dad she and there's
no proof and I'm not alleging that she
was for comedy purposes we're bringing
this up but my mom she's told me she
said I want you to start fixing your own
plate and I started doing it and I
stopped getting sick so I don't know if
she was trying to kill us divorce her
too she left him too I mean that's uh
you know my dad you know was there I
guess was probably a little bit of cash
Andor land she could have got her hands
on yeah that's true I mean and my dad
she left cuz neither one of you would
die these
Hillbillies there a he-man hillbilly we
got over here you're drinking Freon like
Mountain Dew ladyy I got a slug in her
right
lung got your work cut out for you need
a little more than Annie freeze to get
me yeah it I mean it's true I don't know
crazy he's like I they just won't
die I try to do it the illegal I'm just
going to file for a divorce whoa those
slave boys are fortified what was the uh
what would do you have any formal
education what are we talking
about make it sound like we just pulled
him out of a hole well I did graduate
high school I will say I was the first
of my my you know mom's kids to graduate
high school that was a big deal and your
mom graduated high school my mom
graduated my dad graduated my dad did
some
college I mean he's a [__] leader of
he's doing all right but I tell you what
having a guy from that went to
University of Michigan your house really
brings the bar up it really did I will I
will be honest I mean I give a lot of
credit to my brother-in-law I mean I
mean my accent when you listen to me as
a kid I have a Southern accent now but
when you hear me as a kid you're at the
end of my special I have a little video
I was going to say you need to inate
those videos moving for they're so funny
I put a little cuz I have a joke about
uh you know my my dad in this ditch and
killing a frog and stuff like that and
uh but at the
end but you know just Breeze right past
that call it
Tuesday well my you know my dad when I
was a little kid my I remember my dad my
dad had a pool my dad had a put in above
ground or INR
INR this is when he married this this
this third wife not not his current wife
but the third wife he was really trying
to up his game he remodeled his house he
was real like trying to be up you know
and and and the your Now new stepmoms
are they more Housewives or are they
working or they well my stepmom Works my
my new stepmom is a real saint of a lady
I mean I you know and I'm not just
trying to trash my dad here but I do
think that uh you know the only reason
this 20y year thing has happened is
because of this lady I mean she's a real
saint of a woman uh just a real strong
country lady and uh she's just like you
know know you could tell my dad's
beating her down
emotionally sure sure but but she's
hanging in there uhhuh okay and uh and
then I have a younger sister uh that by
my dad and and and my stepmom and so I
always like to say my younger sister not
related to my older sisters I always
think there's a lot of asterisks with
your family yeah and then my you know my
middle sister the one that's N9 years
older than me she has married she
married a guy that she's been married
for I don't know maybe 30 years they've
been married a long time which is
amazing uh and she um uh she's the one
that smoked while she was pregnant
probably both of her kids and they're
fine though yeah they're all tough you
know what I mean can't poison them
either yeah now they all Vape you know
what I mean so they're back on it yeah
uh but uh yeah my one my one of my
nephews just started vaping I always
thought everybody used Vape to quit
cigarett no the the younger kids are
just vaping yeah it blows my mind
you're just getting in you didn't even
do the cool thing the cigarettes I kind
of resent that I'm like yeah you you got
to you know got to fly a little too
close to the Sun and then peel it back
and start vaping yeah you got to do the
cigarette so you can feel like The Vape
is healthy yes yeah you know and I got a
friend he still tells me that the Vape
saved his life so I don't know he's got
a his Instagram is devoted to vape
really he loves it huh he's a big Vape
guy what was uh school like what was uh
can't believe we're only at school so
far we got to you got to come back every
every time you're in New York we do a n
every 3 days we need you back well
school was great I loved how far away
was it how did you get there who was
packing your lunch well when I was when
I was growing up until we moved living
in the trailer it was you know it was
when was the move to when I was 14 you
guys she moved your mom moved into a
house yes okay I moved just before I got
a learner license uh learner permit
which was my which was like at the time
the greatest thing in the world because
I was always ashamed that I had the ad
and I don't know why but I guess you're
just a kid and it's like I was always
ashamed that my address was Lot 8 Moors
trailer park right if I just lived in a
trailer on some land then it would be
you know 4250 County Road but because I
had Lot 8 Moors trailer park it was like
everybody knows I'm poor yeah you know
so I didn't want cuz when you get your
driver's license everybody wants to see
they're like oh let's see your license
and then your addresses right there so I
moved po bo just in time yeah
exactly it's a little place I
keep I got a couple places you
know come by on the weekend
yeah okay so and and then school was you
know you know 15 minutes away it wasn't
too but I was school bus bus would come
to the trailer park everybody hop on I
would do the bus uh I did you know I do
a little both my mom worked third shift
so oh okay so for a while it was like
you know I get up I get get on the bus
and my mom comes home sleeps and then
she picks me up from school okay we had
the old alarm clock you know
that and my mom would always know that
when she showed up if she could hear
that alarm clock when it meant I missed
the bus really and so she would come in
mad because she's like all right now you
got to now I got to drive you and I'm
not going to get sleep uh but yeah we
had um my bus I lived like on the cusp I
could had could have gone to the More
Country School borgard More Country yeah
or I went to opala high school which is
uh like the city school how big of a how
big of a class gr you know it's
literally called like a high school
it's that's funny that's
funny
it's that's very funny Toby's great with
word play yeah opica you know is the
full name of the town but that's very
funny I've never heard that like a high
school that's it's like a high
school
well I think our high school was pretty
good for for the area now I grew up
right next to Auburn University so okay
Auburn High was always the Rival you
know they were always the fancy school
but in our County was four schools so
there was two there was Bula borgard bu
was always kind of like you know kind of
like the methy school borgard was real
redneck opica was a little redneck
little ghetto we kind of had a we kind
of had a you knowx yeah we had a Vibe
about us
yeah we we had a better football team
you know what I mean we were good that's
all that matters put them points up baby
yeah okay and how big of a was your
graduating class do you remember uh I
don't know I feel like I would be off no
I feel like 200 300 people Prett yeah
High School it wasn't like like some of
the country schools like where my Step
Brothers went to school it was like you
know it was you had one class was like
32 people you maybe 20 people and that
was kindergarten through 12th grade you
would be with those same kids yeah yeah
we had a you knowy tradition yeah we had
a you know and you know but it you know
I got um I got one time when I was a
senior in high school I got uh well
let's go Middle School I got I there was
a girl uh she had I had this fake hand
for Halloween and I was playing with it
and she was a real big girl uh I never
like to say her name because I'm still
afraid of her and she uh took the hand
from me and and stole it and then I went
to get it back and she pinched my hand I
tried to get it and I pushed her head a
little bit and then she comes back the
teacher's out of the room and she
stabbed me three times with a pencil
Jesus uh I jumped in the corner I was
trapped and she was just stabbing me uh
and then the whole class saw it and then
when the teacher came back I was just
like I just stood up and I go she just
stabbed me I was like your honor I was
like I'm not I'm not and then I got a
day of in school suspension because I
pushed her head and I never saw her
again no [__] terrified of her so I'll
never use her name but uh she's out
there looking for you with the fake hand
she's watching right now you're getting
shived at opica what was that other
school like dude well you know I mean
they were the country school so I don't
know I mean they were just doing meth
and sure M Lord and uh would you buy
your lunch at school or would you pack a
lunch do a little bit of both I would
buy a lunch and I would pack a lunch and
what we what was what kind of what was
the grocery store that your mom went to
well we would go like a Piggly Wiggly or
like a wind Dixie those were kind of
southern grocery stores at and how was
the nutrition what was uh what were you
eating terrible nutrition I mean I I
really do thing I have acid reflux to
this day and he me too baby and I think
it's due to just no like I one thing
that I'm mad about my dad that much
baloney yeah my dad bulldozed all those
apple trees and I think I haven't seen
an apple since when I was a kid I think
those apple trees were the only
nutrition I got I would just be eating
you know it's like nowadays we call
those organic apples but back then they
were just apples he had plum trees uh
pear trees really figs uh wild
blackberries that's where I was getting
all my did he get rid of all that or did
he just the apple trees just the Apple
the pear tree still there he got rid of
the plum tree and then he had two fig
trees that's awesome and the Fig just
recently he had one one fig tree is
giant one was real small and I go I go
why do you think that small one never
got big like the other one he goes I
don't know next time I'm there the small
fig tree he's killed it and gotten rid
of it I was like I didn't mean for you
to kill I wasn't telling you to [__]
whack them off yeah he's produ it's
producing figs I don't know what you're
doing but yeah I used to eat um you know
cereal was mainly what I would eat I
love cereal I just I I never had to do
the bag we would we would spring for the
cereal sugar cereal sugar cereals Fruity
Pebbles Sugar Smacks Corn Pops
Wonderbread uh no Wonderbread we were
just doing regular old white bread
uh you know and it back then bread would
mold you know bread really never molds
now I don't know what's going on got a
longer shelf like and we would just pick
the mold off you know and eat around the
bread a lot of grilled cheeses with
American cheese one of my my me and my
CRA single slices craft singles yeah
shout out to it one of my me and my
sister's favorite thing you take a bowl
and then you break up some craft cheese
and you put a little margarine in there
and then put it in the microwave for
about 30 seconds it makes a delicious
cheese dip it's so good eat it with some
lays little hillbilly queso that ain't
bad it's the best that you I mean it's
like it's so good you started off I was
like where the [__] is he going with
this we have to put that in the cookbook
that's pretty good I already thought Dy
slay cheese fondue hillbilly fondue it's
so good what are you dipping in there
lay chips you know like Ruffles you want
a ruffle so you got a thickness to it
yeah get a little yeah all right little
structure yeah yeah you it needs to be
be able to hold that cheese yeah a d
cheese and you have to I yeah it is I'm
not talking to a [__] R parmesan over
here yeah you know and then we would do
sometimes we would do this is my like
before I came along my sister always
tells me that my mom and my two sisters
before in between the her those
marriages they said they were real poor
right like they were like I was spoiled
to them to them yeah uh but they were
talking about being real poor so a thing
they used to do and we would do this
sometimes we would fry up bacon and then
eat that with the cornflakes you eat
cornflakes and then eat the bacon and
it's like milk like a bowl of cereal
cereal and then you just kind of have a
side of bacon that you're eating with it
and weirdly delicious I see that yeah
that makes sense yeah little kind of
salty and a little sweet sweet type
thing and uh yeah and then you know we
would do we had this my my mom would do
this canned roast beef kind of thing
where it's was like a it's like easily
you could do in a crock pot but you know
open the can it's got the meat and then
we put toast and put the meat on it kind
of like a ofen faced uh roast beef s
Beef we do canned roast beef we do
salmon patties sometimes where do canned
salmon make a little salmon cake fry it
up on the pan I don't even think I've
ever seen can I didn't know that salmon
was a real fish until I really until I
was in my 20s and I moved to Charleston
South Carolina to actually see it in
fish form yeah and I worked at a
restaurant and I was like whoa ain't
even in a can I mean I'm I was such an
idiot I was like I
mean Chef let me show you this cheese
dip real quick you want to get this on
the menu you got 30 seconds my whole 20s
was like I was such a drinker such a
weird alcoholic just idiot that I it
took me my whole 20s to like gain any
level of sophistication whatsoever and
uh I mean I was just such a I mean I
would black out I was just such a dumb I
was kind of I'm kind of right there with
you yeah it when I turned 30 I kind of
was like oh things are happening outside
of this how old were you the first time
you got drunk uh I was 16 I think which
is late for for uh I had some drinks
here and there with you know dud two a
day I was driving every in a
while you know I mean uh you know my M
my mom dated a guy my mom always dated
these guys that were like alcoholics
they were never like I always thought
they were fun they always look like fun
people but they were always drinking you
know they could do things like I
remember one alcoholic boyfriend built a
front porch for us at the trailer and
it's like they were all you know they
always just seemed fun yeah well I think
with as my family is very similar of
like fun drunks and then it as they get
older it gets less and less fun when
you're in your 20s and 30s and you're
like four hey we're drinking beers
building the deck here have one dusty
but when you start hitting 50 it gets a
little bloomy yeah you're right I you
know IA was doing comedy in Johnson City
Tennessee one time and these people it
was only 10 people at the in the club
and this was years ago and these people
uh they like in their 50s they were so
drunk and they got real hostile with me
like so much so that the manager of the
club I watched him kind of back out of
the room he's like I'm not dealing with
this oh man that sucks and then after
the show I saw them leave this is this
club was in a hotel I saw them leave and
like trip and fall over the trash can
outside and they're like in their 50s
and I was so mad at them but then I saw
him I was like ah I just feel bad for
you now drunk idiots y just like H this
was your night out huh what' you do last
night oh I went to a club it was great
had a great time fell into the trash
dumpster any vacations growing up uh a
little bit I remember going to Disney
World with with my dad and my stepmom
and my brothers we did that uh but
mainly we would go to like Gatlinburg
Tennessee that was my my uncle my mom's
brother worked in the hotel business so
we would kind of vacation wherever he
was working got cuz he would get us a
free room de okay so he worked in uh
decar Alabama for a while which is where
my sister and brother-in-law met the
University of Michigan guy he was coming
down from Michigan to go to Atlanta he
was thinking of move into Atlanta and uh
he met my sister at this hotel and then
they started dating sh when you guys
were on one of your vacations yeah no
kidding yeah
that's wild talking about fate yeah and
I remember this vacation in Decor I
think all we did was go to the hotel
you're just hanging at the hotel yeah we
went to the hotel and they had a pool
that was like indoor and outdoor that
you could swim under the thing all you
need baby yeah and it was just like I
just remember that it was just like this
is I remember just playing in that pool
yeah a hotel pool at age 8
n it was amazing and then but my uncle
then started he I remember he worked at
a hotel in Nashville uh and then he
started work he worked in Gatlinburg and
Pigeon Forge and so we would go there a
bunch that would be the spot I remember
going to Dollywood I saw I saw Toby
Keith at Opry land Jes in Nashville but
like seeing the pope at the vatic how
old were you I was uh I don't know maybe
10 or so my mom was a huge Toby she was
in the fan club was at the height of his
success my mom also had a VHS camcar she
didn't film as much but I got a video
she's filming all the Christmas
ornaments we had one of those big old
TVs the wooden with the TV in the bottom
and on the top she had a Christmas
Village y nice with the snow and the
little yeah and then she was filming it
and then she filmed this bookshelf of
all these Santa Claus oraments the whole
and then she Zooms in and it's a picture
of Toby Keith in a turtleneck framed in
amongst the Santa
Clauses you know was fun when you put a
couple Matchbox cars in those little
Villages drive it's all right yeah I
love that man how were the grades grades
were good I mean I was an AB student
SATs did you take them I didn't take I I
I was AB until high school and then I
was C's okay um but I never failed
anything I almost failed Spanish class
but you know that was you know happens
mostly accent related yeah exactly and
my teacher was pregnant left halfway
through the
year that's a mulligan right there the
teacher's not even committed to it it's
like come on what do you want from
me and uh but yeah um I you know college
prep was not on anybody's mind like my
you weren't going to college well my
parents wanted me to go to college but
they weren't doing anything to help me
and nobody was helping me prepare and
maybe that's happening to a lot of
people I don't but I just know my
friends were like are you taking the SAT
you taking the act and I'm like I don't
know and they're like oh you know it
costs $50 or whatever and I go oh
definitely not it's going be it's going
to be a hard note from the slay Camp
over here and I be saying [__] like guys
VHS ain't going anywhere we're s and I
did go to a community college for I went
for two days uh I I signed up I I I
mainly was you know it's like I had in
high school it's like you're you're in
these rooms and you got all SE
attractive women around you all the time
and you're like this is amazing I I like
school a lot I like going I didn't skip
school a lot because I liked being there
I was like I got to be in this room with
a captive audience that I got to make
laugh yeah and there girls in there and
I'm like this is great and then suddenly
I'm out of high school and I'm just
getting high with my buddies all day and
I'm like where are the women where are
those broads at so I signed up for
Community College and I had to take like
a uh and I was a pretty good student but
I had to take like a like a test to find
out where you were at or whatever and I
ended up like taking like a some kind of
like lower level math and English sure
and I got in there and there were no
girls in my classes at all and I was
like this is not the college part lame
I'm out of here and I did each class one
time they were on different days I did
and then I was like all right I'm out of
there you went to Community College for
two days of scope for chicks it was beat
and you got out of there respected
that's a that's a that's chess right
there part's lame dude and I was like I
don't know what I'm going to do with my
life but uh it ain't going to be this
path and then you moved to Charleston
and then you know then I hung around I I
after that I I bought my childhood
trailer back my sister moved into it
when we moved out and then she traded it
in for another trailer which apparently
you can do that and uh because trailers
have registration like a car you know so
uh the trailer I went to the trailer
company they racing houses for pink
slips yeah yeah and I whoever can build
this deck fast enough gets the trailer
and I offered to buy it from them and
they said they would sell it to me for
$11,000 and looking back if I had any
negotiation skills I bet I could have
got it way down yeah they didn't even
want to deal with it the th000 was the
first price and it was so low I was like
oh yeah I'll listen I'll do
12200 yeah it's kind of like comedy you
know I feel like they must thought this
too where like you like a gig uh you say
I'll do it for this much money and the
place goes okay and you go dang should
have asked for more [__] you know I feel
like that's what the trailer company did
they go thousand bucks I go I'll take it
they're like dang I could have got more
out of this both walking away so I moved
back into that trailer on where on what
property uh it's still in the trailer
park it was just still sitting there I
think that was part of it for them they
were like we don't want to move this
trailer we don't want to deal with this
a different plot than you grew up on
same very same exact spot theck still L
yeah the deck actually my sister lived
next door to us for a long time and they
had built a deck and so we moved that
deck from off that to our back porch so
we had a we had deck on both sides
that's crazy deck kind of stole the deck
from a rental trailer and how old are
you at this time I'm 19 and what are you
doing for work well I I was working at
Western sizin waiting tables and I I I
went to the Army recruiter office and I
joined the army I went and I said I'm
going to join the Army and then I went I
went through my uh physical I went to
Montgomery the capital of Alabama did
the whole thing I got kind of like a
loose swearing in I they say it's kind
of you're kind of being sworn in but you
don't get officially sworn in until you
go to boot camp okay so I got my you
know boot camp I got all that and then I
got back and then you know I was smoking
a lot of weed at the time so my recruit
yeah my recruiter real name's
Allen so my you got so high you w up in
the Navy well it is true I was I was
high at Western Sizzlin and this guy
started telling me how great the Army
was and so I left work that day and went
to the recruiter's office and uh and my
recruiter was trying to figure out how
much weed I was smoking trying to figure
out how to help me get clean you know
and telling me
uh you know all the lies to tell the
army so that I could get those
recruiters yeah they're like teaching me
to lie to the government to get into the
government and so I did it I did all
that and then when I got home from uh
you know the the whatever swear yes my
my recruiter goes he goes I probably
shouldn't tell you this but he goes I
know you like to smoke weed and he's
like you're going to get shipped off in
30 days so if you want to smoke weed you
know do it tonight you know so I went
out and that night I got arrested uh for
weed and underage consumption of alcohol
and so my ship off date came after my uh
my court date came after my ship off
date so I couldn't get shipped off so I
could have went still instead of
probation but I would have lost all my
bonuses and all that stuff so I just
decided not to go to the Army and so I
uh had and I and I was supposed to get
shipped off in August of 2001 mhm so
would have been in boot camp When
September 11th happened so I was like so
happy that I didn't go and uh and then I
uh so I lost my license for nine months
and I got two years unsupervised
probation which means I didn't have to
take drug test but I sat so the next
nine months I just sat in this trailer
and you know did drugs with my buddies
and worked at Office Depot I had this
nice you quit the restaurant job I quit
well I quit the restaurant job to go to
I was like I even there was this girl
that I this is like the most
embarrassing Time Of My Life I even
sounds like the coolest dude what are
you talking about well I had this girl
that I really liked you know and I'm
like I'm like acting like you know I'm
like don't get married while I'm in the
Army you know like I didn't have the I
didn't have the balls to ask her out but
I was doing everything I could do to get
her to be like I want to be with you
call that playing the zone defense I'll
be back for you when I got back from
Vietnam yeah I mean I was you walk back
in sock I'm a
burnout
and H yeah it was so embarrassing never
even talked to the Army you come back
you tell you you're a Green
Beret didn't get in said I was too
strong they wanted to keep it a fair
fact Dusty nuts dude I love it it's so
embarrassing I uh I just think of the
things that I said to that girl ra every
that she probably liked me I I looked
back
think all she she was like in in my mind
I'm thinking she's like if you would
just ask me out on a date naked in your
bed put some clothes on will you I would
say yes if you would just ask me but
instead I'm like send I've given her
songs on a mixtape I'm like I I yeah
it's the most embarrassing time of my
life uh and it was 20 years ago and I
wish it never happened sure I know it
very well my friend course but so I lost
my license but I had a job at Office
Depot and I could get to work so I had
this buddy and he had he was uh he got
kicked out of his parents house now my
lot my trailer was paid off my lot rent
was 120 a month so my friend was like my
friend was like if you let me live with
you for free you know I'll give you a
ride to work every day and I'll be and I
was like you know what I need that and I
said so we worked it out and I was like
but I can't we can't be messing around
here this is no goofing around you're my
livein driver yeah if this is our deal I
don't want to come out of work and you
not be there yeah so it was cool he had
had this Isuzu Rodeo he had these 17in
rims with a system so every day at work
I got picked up by this guy in a really
cool looking car and it was pretty
awesome he would pick you up and drop
you off every day every day that guy
getting free rent that's his job and he
sold weed right so my deal with him was
I was like you can sell weed out of my
trailer but you got to smoke with me for
free MH so it he would pick me up from
work with like sounds like the greatest
setup ever with like a blunt and I would
get in and we would get high on the way
home and it was like it was awesome and
a lot of my friends didn't really want
to buy a bag of weed they just wanted to
get high so they would come over and
this guy had worked out a system where
people would just give him like five
bucks sit around and smoke a blunt and
then he would just roll a bunch of
blunts and we would all just sit there
and play you know PlayStation 2 and get
high and it was like a really great time
and it's like I think think about it
sometimes and I'm like this cop that
arrested me and I'm not mad at all cops
but this cop arrested me and he was such
a like a prick about it like he was like
in his mind I'm stopping a drug addict
but what he did was he stopped me from
going to the Army where I potentially
would have changed my life and instead
sat in a trailer for the next two years
doing drugs and I'm like but I also
ended up being a comedian and things are
going well so I'm happy for it but you
know I mean that is a tale and we're at
19 years old yeah but it was such a
great time it was like I look back on
that and I just think those years are
great I remember one time we had this
Tekken Tag Tournament I had all these
buddies over at my trailer the doors are
open we're all smoking weed and
cigarettes I mean there's just smoke
everywhere in there it's just a me and
we're just hanging I'm like this was
such a great time yeah it got a little
darker we got in you know to various
drugs here and there and then like what
are we talking you don't mind sharing
you know uh I don't know I never really
talk about it uh I feel like I talk
about a lot of you know I've just now
put out this special where I had like
eight minutes of weed jokes and it's the
first time I really hit some realistic
weed jokes and I'm like 41 years old and
I'm still like feeling out my dad on it
I'm like hey what you think of the
special you know and uh but you know we
just got you know you got into you know
some typical Alabama drug got you like
and that you know and actually it wasn't
really that gasoline moonshine mayy it
wasn't really that what are we tap
dancing around here it wasn't really
that dark for me to be honest I had a
blast that was
uh pretty much
ruled lying but you know we would drink
a lot too we would I I remember my bud I
had a buddy his name was John and he
would uh he would go to jail you know I
don't it never was we never were real
clear on why why he was going to jail he
was such a good nice guy but he would
just you know I think he got in trouble
one time and then he just kept violating
his probation and then he would just
disappear for a while and I remember he
wrote me a letter from jail one time
talking about how when he got out you
know he's like I want to I want to
change I don't want to be smoking weed I
don't want to be drinking and then he
got out of jail came to my house and my
other buddy who just you know he's still
my friend but just kind of a real prick
move was like just lights up a blunt cuz
my friend wanted to change his life he
was like oh we're still living like this
and then my we end up getting drunk and
high my buddy who's like want to change
his life that night we're drunk we're
out in the yard we got grass up to our
knees we're getting eat up by all kind
of different insects and we're shooting
each other with the BB gun out
there like it's like you've been out of
prison for a day this is this is where
We've Ended up yeah and I think he's
okay I think he's doing okay he messages
me on Facebook sometimes I think he's
he's okay but it's like a lot of these
guys are like my friends and I want to
get together with them but I don't drink
anymore and I'm like you know what I
don't need my life's going well I got
have my wife I got kids you don't want
to end up in the High Grass shooting
each other I don't need to Dance with
the Devil yeah I was like I don't really
need that in my life but I got I was my
li My license was suspended for 2 years
or uh 9 months and I was on probation
for two years and then once I got off
probation that's when I moved to
Charleston I sold the trailer moved to
char what you get for the trailer I got
2500 go yeah flipped it Alabama real
Alabama real estate loog [__] Tycoon
over here let go lift it my
brother-in-law who was the Michigan took
the one porch with you yeah he was the
Michigan grad he worked for a company
called craftmade cabinets and this was
at a time when like companies were just
booming and like so if somebody these
are very expensive cabinet so if
somebody would order the you know and
get the wrong color it would just sit at
a Lowe's store right so my
brother-in-law took me to a Lowe's and
we picked up one of those sets of the
cabinets were probably $2,000 cabinets
and we put in this $1,000 trailer and it
was sweet oh I meant to tell you I don't
know how I got sidetracked but the
particle board thing with the holes in
the floor my mom would rip all that out
and put in new plywood so this trailer
uh you know it had great flooring in it
and we would install good cabinets good
cabinets I mean it was on the outside it
looked really bad a lot of kind of mold
on it but on the inside it was pretty
keep the burglars away it was yeah it
was actually very good but I was I I
found some pictures of me like uh you
know drinking with my buddies in there
and there was this one wall where it's
like bare sheetrock but like you know
how like sheetrock has like a little
paper on it and it looked like all the
paper was ripped just and we had a lamp
like kind of hanging on a nail up there
and I'm like I really thought my trailer
looked good but it was like at the time
this was the worst wall in the place but
we got a lot of but you know what it's
like the beauty of of women is like
they're just such nice people that I was
still having girlfriends even living in
this filth as some weird no driver's
license
alcoholic had a weed connector
yeah had a Chau what are you talking I
still had like pretty women that would
date me and I'm like this is great women
are such nice people man man I mean
Dusty sleigh a home run a home run I
think we we which we've never done which
we should just do just call we have to
have a part two next time you're in New
York I would love to we'll do the from
age 19 on yeah still and all that stuff
this is so fun you guys just let me tell
you about myself and you let us make fun
of
nice Studio your studio is definitely
not garbage no no no shout out to
patreon yeah and it's uh yeah I
appreciate you guys lot of fun buddy we
can't thank you enough for coming in
gang the special is working man it is
out on Netflix right now it's in the top
10 do yourself a favor get over there
and check it out Dusty anything else you
want the folks out there to know website
dates all my social media is Dusty slay
uh my uh website is Dusty slay.com and
so everything's there uh I have a
YouTube is fun I put a lot of content on
YouTube a lot of stuff on Instagram
those are my two favorites I mean I'm on
all of them but those are my two
favorites but uh you know so I'm active
there and I will comment back if you say
nasty things about me my wife tells me I
got to stop doing it but
I I respect it but I can't stop and I
try to not be like really like nasty
because I don't want to make myself look
bad but I do try to get witty with it
and just be like why you being mean to
me like this one guy just comment it
on man d man you can take a guy out of
the Tall Grass take a tall grass out of
he's like this this well it's funny that
he he said this now that I'm on this
podcast he goes this special was
literally garbage and then he goes I had
to turn it off after 6 minutes and I
just was like why you watching garbage
for 6 minutes you know I mean have some
respect for yourself top 10 on Netflix
baby how about that huh don't lie but
then the guy starts lecturing me he's
like oh you have a and I don't just
laugh about the comment I'm like you
just said really mean things about me
and now you're like hey dude don't be
reading these you know what I had to go
through to get to this Jesus Christ
buddy thank you so much you got to come
back got to have you back next time
you're in town for sure we love it man
kiby what do you got for him uh we are
planning the 2024 tour the only date on
sale right now is New York City Town
Hall on May 9th get your tickets they're
moving quick and the a card game all
available at rug garbage.com we love you
gang Dusty we love you buddy thank you
so much foring you guys I appreciate you
having me gang we love you and we'll see
you next week peace